and the key for me as an entrepreneur is
if i lose 91 times and i win seven times
the seven times will offset the 98 at
bets and most people don't see that
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
gary welcome to five questions
thank you for having me or should i say
welcome back this is my sixth interview
with you since 2007
uh and congratulations on 12 and a half
an amazing read of course
you know not too much of it surprises me
based on knowing you for such a long
period of time and it's your sixth
business book and of course
did anything did anything pop out as
somebody who obviously has interacted
and consumed and we've interacted a lot
was there anything that
was caught you uh you know what for me i
think it was reinforcement for something
that i've been thinking about and you
and i were similar in many ways
obviously you know
you know i came from like an immigrant
family hard workers you know i've been
working since i was a little kid like
you and and so like i don't know the
work ethic thing is is penetrated
through everything you've done of course
but one of the things that you said
actually
is that curiosity is one of the top soft
skills that you mentioned the book and
to me that makes so much sense because
when i think about what drives me it's
curiosity it's the reason why i have a
research business and i want to uncover
the biggest workplace trends you you
focus on marketing consumer trends and
just overall trends about where we're
going you know in the future so
curiosity like i even you know i was
talking to david copperfield and he even
said curiosity is why he got into magic
so the fact that that was one of the the
soft skills and emotional intelligence
skills that you focused on i think that
really resonated with me because it
reinforced how i'm thinking about what
motivates me and why i do what i do
i love it
so going on to that i love how you
included it and most people don't think
of curiosity as a scale
how has your curiosity led to you
experiment
and have breakthroughs in business and
your life
i mean it's foundational for me you know
in hindsight my
my attachment to youth
and child
ish
like
optimism and and curiosity um
is essential i think curiosity leads to
um
opportunities humility i think is
actually a very important partner to
curiosity and innovation
so not only am i inherently curious like
oh what is that or why do people like
that even at this point in my career
where my time has
for lack of a better word humbled me in
what its value is on paper
i'm willing to spend 70 hours
which is
to go down an empty road
yeah right
people well one of your great examples
gary is you have
you know invested or participated in
social networks that haven't succeeded
but you've learned from those
experiences too which has helped you
then later invest and make decisions
that have greatly benefited i i would
have been the first investor in tinder
if that wasn't incubated at iac
uh because of what i learned with yo
bongo which was a big loss for me
uh and
and
tried to get into highlight
which was a loss
and so i
think that's exactly right i think
people under value
they really undervalue learnings they
really do
reps the at-bats
you know i think when we say this is a
good analogy actually first time i've
ever thought of it hey go in the gym and
take a thousand free throws
uh i think everyone who's listening
right now is like oh that's gonna help
that person be a better shooter
what i don't think we go deeper into is
realizing that person's gonna miss
397 shots in that session if they're
like early in their basketball life
that's how i treat business with
curiosity i'm willing to miss 397
shots so that later i'm an nba player
and i think curiosity
along with humility
lead you down paths that actually
occasionally become fruitful and the key
for me as an entrepreneur is
if i lose 91 times and i win seven times
the seven times will offset the 98 at
bats
and most people don't see that and you
can curiosity
yeah and you can't replace actually
doing it as in i've done tons of
research on this about how people best
learn
and from a workplace perspective on the
job training trumps everything because
you're actually doing it and learning
firsthand what works what doesn't work
what you like what's going to benefit
the business you're measuring nothing is
more obnoxious to me than watching
business students
give operators advice
when they've never actually run a
business
it could be right in theory but it lacks
context absolutely and um and and
practicality often and
you know and that's not to say i mean
i'll give you good example
head coaches often times never play the
sport professionally
um but they've played it somewhat
normally and it's a little bit of
context but you can be a great head
coach and not be a great player and
that's fine
but yes i i think curiosity is a
massively underrated
ward in the business world
and that's what this book was about i
mean kindness
i mean
when is kindness even been part of the
business lexicon ever
and i've been around and to me
and it was way worse before you were
around
and and and for and me right and and for
me it's the obvious way to build
something meaningful long term
people sticking around for the long term
leads to continuity
continuity a good atmosphere is less
political thus people are actually
focused and going fast
and so it's interesting stuff absolutely
and curiosity is only one of the 12
essential emotional skills that you
cover in the book and the other thing
that i thought was interesting is
there's a half
so which skill do you feel weakest in
and how are you trying to improve it so
you can be more effective in every area
of your life yeah so the book is called
12 and a half and my point in the book
is like these are the 13 traits that i
subjectively believe currently based on
my experiences with myself and others
uh
really are foundational for modern
business success
the half comes in because i'm i feel
like i'm very far along with the 12. and
here's my half and other people have
their halves but my half is
which is a stunner for a lot of people
who don't know me well or more
importantly from almost everybody who's
listening who knows me as gary b on a
podcast or on stage but doesn't know me
as gary vaynerchuk an executive
my great half my whole career has been
candor which is wild
because
the ability to be cancerous in
interviews or on stage or on television
or on podcasts is a strength of mine you
know i i get unlimited like hey gary i
love your no [ __ ] approach i really
appreciate you shooting it straight but
as an executive
deli you know speaking to the masses
with you right now
it's really easy because i'm not
speaking to an actual human being
speaking to
tamara or sally or ricky or chanel
is so much more challenging for me and i
always tried to skirt around the bone if
i had to give critical feedback it would
always still come in a package that was
much more about optimism i would skirt
around the actual issue and i was trying
to find different ways to get them there
without telling them like hey you're
really struggling or you're not good at
this or you know like it just i was
always scared that it would lead to fear
and and spiral out of control and i i
really struggled with candor and and two
or three years ago i started getting
better at it a lot better at it because
i i was my subconscious became my
conscious i'd always known it was always
hanging in there dan like i always knew
like man for somebody who really doesn't
care about the money
really truly like meaning of course i
want some but like it's not about that
it's not about this it's about the
process i love being liked i like being
admired why do i even have anybody who's
ever worked for me not love me oh wait a
minute it's been this candor thing right
dan you're doing great dan you're doing
great dan you can get this damn listen
the way you're working with johnny
listen maybe you'll just
and then all of a sudden dan you're
fired by the way by the way i just gary
what you said is so important because
you want to be like very few people will
admit they want to be liked but i think
at everyone's heart if they were very
honest with themselves they want to be
liked as well so i adore how many other
people do you know who says i want to be
liked but that that's they do want to be
liked i i i love being liked i also
often interview say i don't care what
people think that's actually equally
true i can hold both of those feelings
what i mean by that is if johnnypants99
says you suck garyvee it's hard for me
to have weight in that i care a lot more
what you think of me dan than
johnnypants93 because we've interacted a
lot over a decade i care a hell of a lot
more with alex raffington what she
thinks of me she's one of my three
admins and really knows me more than she
i care about her opinion of me way more
than i care about your opinion of me and
so that's what i mean but all in all i
want johnnypants93 i want you and i want
her to like me because i'm aware that i
got very fortunate
lucky a word that i hate using because i
think people weaponize it but
very lucky and fortunate that i was
given natural dna that is good parented
well circumstances that led to good work
ethic and kindness and a million other
things so yeah i mean uh anyway candor
is my half and when people go through
this book whether it's gratitude so many
people lack gratitude it's wild humility
is impossible you know i come with heavy
conviction and confidence so people
don't see this in me but the way i
operate my business humility is a core
foundation of what's going on with me
um you know empathy is well documented
at this point in my career i need my
damn winery after it um and you kind of
go through it self-awareness one of the
things that makes it very easy for me to
navigate is i understand why somebody
wouldn't love me if they just saw a clip
on instagram where i dropped the f-bomb
nine times and i go aggressive at
something and they're like who is this
guy of course many people with the way
they were raised would be turned off by
me that's self-awareness and empathy
that's you know so i really go into it
in this book but it's also things like
tenacity and ambition
and and most of all my biggest argument
in the book is like look the soft skills
are actually the hard skills right like
i can find anybody who can have the
talent to do the math or the creative or
the man like you can find them show me
the people that are excelling at
humanity
and i'll show you a company that if they
hire that way
have a totally different outcome
yeah especially in the world where it's
increasingly getting automated with new
technology if the technology's promise
is to do much of what our hard skills do
for us then what remains is the soft
skills the emotional intelligence
everything you talk about the book now
with tape where you take things a step
further which really makes this book
interesting and valuable aside from just
telling us hey here why these are
important how how they've applied to
your life and made you successful and
other people successful
how do you tailor these individual soft
skills to different people like you
mentioned like a co-worker or secretary
or someone you interact with
environments and situations because
that's where things get complicated for
people
it's the only thing that matters like a
vanilla strategy without context is
always going to lose
i mean i deploy different
tactics on these traits
to the same person
based on the day of the week
i have a different contextual thought
process if it's raining outside versus
sunny on how i have to be as a leader
i literally
like compassionately and empathetically
recognize that there are humans on earth
that are very affected by weather
and so little things matter is what
you're saying in a in a real way
i actually manage differently on a
tuesday than a monday based on the
weather let alone a million other i just
had a tough meeting by the way just now
with a team that has been dominating all
year
now things are different you know some
bad news from the client and now
like i have to be empathetic to that i
can't talk to them today the way i
talked to them yesterday
when you're a true leader
when you're trying to achieve
inhumanity in business and life
if you are not capable of adjusting at
every moment to every nuanced variable
you are creating vulnerabilities
and you know what's really interesting
gary one of the big things i recognized
early during kovid is that everyone's in
a unique situation meaning like i would
talk to people who were pregnant and had
covert i talked to people who had two
children and was like a single mother
living at home or was an entrepreneur or
indeed everyone you know income
situations where you live you know do
you have kids or not there's so many
different variables and as a leader it's
all you know what you said is very
fascinating with you know depending on
the weather time of day et cetera but
it's also like
what's this individual's life
circumstances because work and life as
you know are more blended i mean think
about you know all the remote work that
uh did you
were you able to skim the book the
answer is yes by the way to what you
just said
were you did you skim it were you able
to actually read it
uh i'm more like you yeah i'm more like
you i scared my chest okay yeah that's
that by the way that doesn't even
register for me i'm very grateful for
even knowing it exists let alone
skimming it let me ask you this
did you skim the part where i talk about
a scenario make pretend scenario where
the employee that's upset with the
manager
may want to consider the fact that
something atrocious happened to the
manager's life that day yes so i think
one of the things that i'm really proud
about this book is i think it gives a
holistic
much more nuanced thought which is
when you're an employee
you just have an inherent thing of like
manager
you're what are you gonna do for me [ __ ]
you what i'm gonna do for you or company
what like but we don't deploy em we tend
to talk about empathy down
hey leader have empathy for your people
but we don't talk a lot about hey
employee have empathy for your manager
if a manager has proven to you that she
or he has been solid for a year
and something atrocious happened today
out of left field
i see people canceling that manager like
oh i knew it [ __ ] you sam or sarah
what about having compassion and empathy
to the thought of like man i hope
everything's okay with
sarah or sam this is out of character we
don't do enough of that cordialness
stability
empathy
we need more
and all of my researchers you know i've
interviewed tens of thousands of
executives managers hr leaders employees
and you know what's really interesting
the higher up you go in the hierarchy
the more they're suffering from mental
health 100 and so that yeah i've done a
whole course with linkedin about
managing well-being as a as a leader
because they're the ones who are
suffering but no one's thinking about it
because they're making more money but
they have more responsibility so that's
more stress dan if i wasn't completely
detached
from everything professionally
my success
my failures
the money
the accolades the haters the all the
pains the fact that every day all that
happens to me is problem after problem
after problem that's all i what i'm a
firefighter i'm a firefighter if i
wasn't completely detached
it would be impalpable
yep
so i love to switch gears as much as
i know that you are like mr nft but
you're also like nfts is like part of
your your career obviously like you're
always for looking you're always testing
you know with your own nfts in the
marketplace you're launching and
everything that you've been doing
so you've said that 98 of nft projects
will go to zero and called for an nft
winter what do you think will be the two
percent that appreciate long-term in
value
i'm not sure i'm incredibly positive
my big bet is crypto punks just given
the nature of its status of
establishment
um what about like ip like you know like
vv with nfts and like disney nfts with
like
marvel and star wars star wars the
problem is people i come from a
collecting background so i'm too smart
good so you know thomas
so you know this not every not even
close to every spider-man has value
what about the first ever spider-man nft
of course
the question becomes though which one
right maybe like versus on chain versus
what if solana wins the day in 12 years
then it's gonna be the first solana
spiderman not the first eth right so
we're too early see where i'm going yeah
there's a lot to think through you could
bridge over to different chains there's
a lot to think through what is actually
an nft versus a digital asset maybe
closed environment
you know decentralized switching it's
switching away from close being a closed
environment though it's going to be a
question the question yeah i know that
but the question will become
will the market accept
it as the first or was it the first that
meant it on main net because they didn't
got it because now it won't be the first
that's so there's all the and all of
it's awesome like i actually have no
idea at a minimum you're having fun and
you're learning
about this space you don't know but
you're willing to you know see what's
going to work and especially for your
business because nfts is rocked i don't
know what you do i also like the fact
that the results are going to be the
results i don't know i have hunches
i will spend my money and put my
reputation on the line against those
hunches and i have the humility and the
confidence
to navigate that because i realize that
if i am wrong
it's incredibly you know this i enjoy
talking about passing on uber twice
well because it's an example it's an
it's a great example of hey you're not
always gonna be right yeah it's also the
truth right like [ __ ] like like
like you know so if crypto punks
disappears in its relevance like and
becomes friendster
right then i'm like okay i was wrong i
shouldn't have bought that and that will
be
just as good learning content for my
audience as if i was right
and i think too many people are attached
to success
i'm
either attached or detached from both
success and failure i'm obsessed
of the oxygen of the process
right you know this you and i grew up in
the revolution
of social media personal brand moments
of that too right that's how we broke
out that's how we broke out yeah you
were very aware because you were
actually there you're not reading it in
my wikipedia you are aware that when i
hit the scene
there was 500 other people that in
theory looked like me right
but when you did wine library tv i would
had no interest in wine gary but i still
watched the show to me that's how i knew
you were going to be successful i think
that's fair you said to yourself because
you're thoughtful about psychology that
okay wait a minute this dude may be
different because i'm not interested in
a subject matter but he's compelling
enough for my interest you could have
talked about anything right what you
didn't know at the time nor did anybody
nor did i myself other than my own
hopes and convictions and intuitions is
that i was obsessed with not
compromising my reputation for anything
at all costs including how i predict aka
observe i don't predict i just talk
early enough
um
the way i handled myself you know i'm
not transactional uh the way i like to
have true relationships
you're smart you know where i'm at at
this point i'm doing this show because
of you
i'm busy i'm busy i don't you know you
know but this is what i like about you
because i think you're awake but i'm a
long-term
gary vee person right it's yeah we'll be
talking when you're you know 70 years
old but i but i think you probably could
have been long-term other people who
along the way decided not to reciprocate
relationships
yeah you know i just i just saw your
future early on and
you know i was like it's it's worth the
investment and and you know you kind of
uh you both reinforced what i knew and
showed me a path forward at the same
time and i think a lot of people would
agree on that that's very nice i'm
incredibly grateful at this point i'm a
40 turning 46 i know we're recording
this on wednesday i don't know when
you're gonna drop it but on november
14th on the sunday um which
when are you dropping this
uh
next week a couple weeks two weeks yeah
yeah so you know like now i'm 46 as
everyone's listening and
[ __ ] man i was a i was i had wisdom at
seven i hung out with 80 year olds
80 year old eastern european jewish
begrudging grandpas on the
at at the park in queens and these 85
year old smug from the old country and
the hard life they were captivated by me
and i of them i to this day
believe that i'm an old soul that i was
born with wisdom and then parented with
it and then circumstanced with it and
the fact that i found my way
to be able to pass it on without
expectation of others
is a gift like thank god i was able to
make money and
fulfill myself with a roof over my head
and food on the table
in a manner that didn't require me to
monetize my audience right i i had so i
got so fortunate right so many people
that are great communicators and do what
i do they're required to monetize their
audience because that's the only way
they can get their selfish needs i was
able to get my selfish needs out of
being a retailer about vaynermedia is a
[ __ ] 300 million a year business i'm
a businessman
that happens to also desperately enjoy
talking to people at scale what the
people on the other end have felt is
wait a minute the other shoe never
dropped with this guy there was no
funnel to this or that or this it was a
real relationship not a transactional
one and that i think has been the
pedestal that i've been able to be put
on by the audience absolutely and what's
your best piece of career advice
that your word is bond
it's really helped me man really
genuinely my dad instilled that in me my
gift of gab
i could have been
a cult leader for [ __ ] christ right
like i am captivating you're right
and the fact that do you know how many
days a year i thank god for making me a
nice person when you know you have a
super communication
superpower you shiver down your spine of
the thought if you weren't in a good
place what damage you could do and i
have history to show me i know who
hitler is i know who mussolini is i know
who jim jones is you know i you know you
look at the history of like when you are
given that gift
of communication you could go gandhi and
martin luther king or you can go hitler
and mussolini and like [ __ ] not that i
want to put myself in those territories
because i stay in a much much smaller
place in society but
i'm aware that and i'm grateful for that
and i and i think everybody has their
version of communication skills i think
a lot of people listening right now
don't realize how much of a legacy and a
good legacy they can leave if they had
the courage
and the self-esteem
to put out things they believe in we can
help each other and unfortunately
negativity is louder than positivity
and that has played out over the last
you know 15 years and i take on a huge
sense of responsibility to speak about
optimism and practicality and and hope
and good stuff because i believe it
absolutely and you're you know we talk
about personal writing we've talked
about this for such a long period of
time whether people call it reputation
or or whatever consistency has always
been important when building a brand as
you know and
the advice that you just shared you've
been sharing this for
way over a decade and it's because i
think because your dad taught you it
when you were younger and it's something
that has stayed with you and it's also i
i understood it was something that was
you know what it actually inspires me
because i do believe it was taught to me
i believe my natural state does have a
little bit of a little too much schmooze
i know who i was at eight i remember how
i sold baseball cards to ten the sale
was more valuable than my honor right it
just whatever it took and you know as
you become a little bit older
you know i was able to be in an
environment where lying was demonized
and so my dad really took a lot of
my vulnerabilities out of me in scaring
me he scared me he scared me straight at
some level and he caught me at 13 14. so
i'm 14 15 16 17 and i start to read it's
almost like working out i reformed and
by the time i became
and then it was just [ __ ] over like i
was just in such a good spot right and
then by the time i'm 22
i'm this
full product of my mom instilling the
majority of the good [ __ ] my dad really
plugging the hole on what could have
been a huge vulnerability and limited my
upside
and here i am as a 46 year old man and
professionally
i am in a very unique spot and have a
lot of opportunity to really shape a
conversation i'm incredibly hungry for
this book i really want people to
understand that the good traits are not
over coddling not soft not
la la la land that actually these good
things actually lead to empires
yeah and this will clearly be part of
your legacy well i hope so everything
you just shared is such great advice i
obviously urge people to read the book
and you know i'll be following you
forever and i just think that the legacy
you live is going to be a really
positive one promoting the you know
emotional intelligence and skills that
people really need not just
professionally but personally and so
thank you so much for being on the show
gary pleasure have a great great day